wenn du Frühstück durchspielen willst
dann mach dir diese breakfast
potatoes brauchen natürlich Kartoffeln
dazu ein bisschen Bacon und Eier wir
hacken den Bacon bisschen klein und wir
lassen ihn aus währenddessen kümmern wir
uns um unsere Kartoffeln die schneiden
wir erstmal in Scheiben die Scheiben
dann wiederum in Stifte und dann in
Würfel sod dass wir am Ende diese
perfekten 1 x 1 cm Würfel haben wenn
unser Bacon ausgelassen ist geben wir
die Kartoffelwürfel dazu das könnt ihr
jetzt mit allen würzen auf das ihr Lust
habt ich nehme mir Paprika scharfe
Paprika cayenpfeffer bisschen
Knoblauchpulver Zwiebelpulver und
normale
Paprika jetzt die Kartoffeln richtig
schön Farbe bekommen lassen und gut
durchbraten nach 15 Minuten haben wir
schon ordentlich Farbe an den Kartoffeln
so wenn die Kartoffeln fertig sind dann
können wir sie auf einen Teller geben
ich liebe sowas ja einfach ein Traum
breakfast potatoos sind fertig dazu
mache ich mir noch Spiegeleier so die
Spiegeleier sind fertig oben auf die
Kartoffeln drauf habe ich noch ein
bisschen Bacon vorbereitet das ist
wirklich ein brutales Frühstück ohne
Witz Ketchup hotsauce Feierabend